[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في مؤتمر انا ابي عندي ثمان سنين
فضاء مفقور جاذبيه ودم مش هيوصل لاطراف
الجسم علشان كده انا رياضي بلعب رياضيات
مختلفه اكتر رياضه بحبها سلاح السيسي لانه
الفضاء واتكلم معكم سؤال
لانه فضيتوا شبح بدله رقده
الفضاء يكون للرياضي
علشان في الفضاء الدم مش هيوصل لاطراف
الجسم علشان كده انا الرياضي بلعب رياضيات
مختلفه اكتر رياضه بحبها سلاح الشيش لانه
بدلته شبه بدله رائد الفضاء
مهمه جدا انه الفضاء يكون مثقف عنده
معلومات مقفول مختلف ابحاول دايما اتعلم
واتطور من نفسي بدات فير وفي مجرم منهم
مجرد ضرب التبانه اللي فيها المجموعه
الشمسيه مجموعه الشمسيه
منهم كوكب الارض اللي احنا عايشين عليه
قبل المريخ اللي جنب كوكب الارض وهو اكثر
كوكب شبه الارض
مركز العلوم وهناك اخدونا في رحله للمريض
المريخ قريب من سطح الارض فيها حاجات كتير
علشان كده لونه احمر في اثار ميه متجمده
الجو حر جدا بالنهار وبرد جدا بجنيه لانه
مفيش الغلاف الجوي زي الارض الانسان لو
فضل الارض بالشكل السيء ده
في المستقبل نعيش
[موسيقى]
لان زي ما قلنا هو اكبر كوكب شبه الارض
لانه زي ما قلنا هو اكبر كوكب شبه الارض
طب ازاي هنعيش على المريخ ونريد تحمل
انسان من تقلبات الحراره
هنعمل تحليل الميه نخرج منها غاز الاكسجين
ونقدر نتنفس
عشان نقدر نتنفس نبقى هنعمل صواب زراعيه
وسطها نعمل مزرعه سمكيه الانسان احتياجاته
للحياه سكن وغزاء
هيقدر يعيش على المريخ بامان قرات النشطين
في الميه من المايه اللي موجوده على الارض
مصدرها بس ضاموا الناس بالفضاء في ناس
كتير ممكن يكون في حياه ميه على كواكب
تانيه
اكبر اكتشف الكواكب المختلفه اللي هما
لاقي عليها حياه عارف انها تحديات لكن انا
واثقه اني اتغلب عليها لان انا نفسي اكون
انسان مميز يعمل تغيير في العالم
[تصفيق]